just continued enjoyment and happiness
and really the music business in all
phases of my life that's the main thing
we finally finally got my house finished
in Nashville so like that portion of my
brain power is gone so I just want to
sit at my piano at the house and write
songs and and watch my boys swim and
play out on the farm and and I just just
make sure that I'm in a good place and
having fun and always pushing myself to
to try new venues and and I mean it is
still incredibly humbling that I get to
come up here to Canada I remember a few
few years ago we started talking about
really me focusing my efforts on growing
my Canadian fanbase and they have they
have supported me above and beyond
anything I ever could have imagined so
it's always things like that you know
so always pushing yourself I think the
day that you don't want to like roll the
dice on something or or go a little bit
outside of your your norm I think it's
kind of when you get a little little
stagnant in this business so um but the
main thing for me is just focus on
enjoying it and being happy and trying
to be a better singer and writer every
day
you